[Musique]
si vous passez au sud de bromont vous ne
remarquerez probablement pas les
millions de tournesol qui s'y trouvent
de fait ils ont perdu leur couleur mais
il amorce dans le silence une dernière
transformation parce qu'on voit lyon
lamine bâ un peu actuellement en studio
ce qu'on pensait être la fleur de
tournesol n'est pas ce qu'on pense à
faire ce soir effectivement la france de
tournesol
c'est pas nécessairement la fleur qui
avec les pétales jaunes c'est on appelle
ça le capture puis en fin de compte la
fleur de tournesol comporte environ
mille à trois mille fleurs à l'intérieur
elle cache la graine de tournesol
factice si on enlève ici on voit que la
graine de tournesol est en train de se
développer à l'intérieur du tournesol
mais je suis en fait les pluies qu'on a
eu cet été juste au bon moment pour
remplir la grille en au complet donc on
a des supers de grains de cette année
c'est une vis sans fin la graine de
tournesol se fait presser avec les cales
puis lui dans le bar issa 901 journée de
me remplir au baril par la suite on le
laisse décanter pour que les sédiments
tombe au fond puis on fait infiltrer ont
fini par se dresse un casting comme
processus
ça peut regarder le maximum
d'instruments dans l'huile
il ya deux types de graines de tournesol
y est la graine de tournesol de
confiserie qu'on mange principalement
covéa une gamme de baseball et puis il
ya la graine de tournesol à lui et qui
est beaucoup plus petit et plus foncée
son compère mettons l'huile de tournesol
à l'huile d'olive c'est quoi les
similarités puis en fait comparativement
à l'huile d'olive qui est très fort
l'huile de tournesol va prendre les
épices et le goût que vous mettez dans
vos réussites donc elle est beaucoup
plus versatile et polyvalente dans la
cuisine nouveau produit l'huile de
tournesol oléique ce qui permet que le
point de chaleur est plus élevé elle se
compare à l'huile de canola donc pour
sauter yacht à miami aucun problème
à val david dans les laurentides de
vaillants tournesol encore en fleurs
accueille les visiteurs
c'est là que nous rencontrons la chef
fanny ducharme qui utilisent la graine
de tournesol d'une façon unique
comment on arrive à utiliser la graine
de tournesol pour faire un risotto sur
la création à cuisine on essaie de
trouver des idées un peu folle 10 10 qui
sort de l'ordinaire
on essayait graines de tournesol graines
de citrouille puis on a adoré la graine
de tournesol
ce qui donne un beau croquant au risotto
on l'apprêté vraiment comme un risotto
donc on est en route s'il est libre et
nous allons être des glaces et ensuite
et enfin du beurre et de la crème puis
vint de la mort puis ça donnait un peu
extraordinaire
c'est vraiment le fun de contraste de
textures entretien parce que
visuellement la graine de tours nation
ressemblent les autos oui je me disais
c'est peut-être ce qui l'a pas ratée
mais c'est même pas de là l'idée qu'on
voulait changer lé le riz pour autre
chose mais je pense que le fer avec la
graine de tournesol
c'est beaucoup moins lourd leyrit
entente elle est beaucoup plus bourratif
qu'une crème matin puis parlant un peu
soutenons parce que plus de protéines
d'agrément journal que tana dans la vie
ouais bravo c'est vraiment bon
direction au quartier des spectacles à
montréal au restaurant l'eau la rosa
c'est un des plus vieux restaurants
végétariens de montréal et puis on
essaye de faire de la bonne bouffe des
plats un peu un peu travaillé dvd
mijoter on est connu pour le nono super
nacho des nachos servi avec une sauce ou
graines de tournesol ouais c'est une
chose qu'on met sur nos nacho qui
remplace un petit peu une sauce fromage
et alors on avait commencé avec la noix
de cajou et puis on avait un problème de
beaucoup de gens et elles sont
allergiques aux noix et puis
je trouve ça intéressant de l'utiliser
une graine qu'on peut trouver au canada
qui est poussé poussé au canada le goût
aussi un petit peu différent un petit
peu plus présent un petit peu plus tôt
sténo restait donc je trouvais ça
vraiment très intéressant on ajoute
plein des pistes dedans on ajoute des
pommes de terre des petits oignons
caramélisés des piments jalapenos pour
donner un petit pointe d'épicés et puis
c'est ça dont je suis vraiment content
de la texture je suis vraiment content
du moule et les clients et capotes
dessus super c'est généreux c'est
savoureux
je peux vous dire de quoi ces face à
cloud final un peu épicé vpc la
péninsule dans l'opinion mais ça goûte
un peu le tournesol
parce que là je vous voyez le fromage
mais manquent pas du tout la phase 1 but
c'est vraiment une chance que sa propre
personnalité qui est sympa d'être format
ou simili quelque chose et c'est
exactement ça qu'on a essayé de faire
faire vraiment une sauce qui coûte qu'il
goûte pas le fromage mais le coût des
ingrédients qu'on utilise très bien
c'est réussi merci merci
tant cette huile je crois qu'avec ma
mère parce qu'on est dans notre champ de
tournesols un coup vous allez tout
devenir somme et d'affectif c'est
vraiment un savoureux ces sacrés qui
m'étonne les huiles de tournesol que
j'ai goûté son petit notre mail omnium
une belle finale un peu noisette
n'empire à découvrir
[Musique]